we have talked before about how when you
have a situation where a particular
population is vulnerable very quickly
grifters come out of the woodwork and
they try to take advantage of vulnerable
people in really sick and disgusting
ways so one example of that I told you
last week this some Christian a
televangelist who was previously in
prison for fraud Jim Baker he and a
naturopath were selling something called
silver solution which they said could
kill or neutralize or destroy or
deactivate the virus that was a scam the
New York Attorney General sent a
cease-and-desist letter yesterday I told
you about televangelist Kenneth Copeland
a guy worth about 760 million dollars he
has been healing people of the virus
through his television during a special
report about corona virus and you
probably aren't going to be shocked to
hear that conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
is Hawking a toothpaste that kills the
virus as well as his food storage stuff
this is Alex Jones who has been kicked
off youtube facebook spotify I guess
he's just publishing content on his
website at this point here's Alex Jones
explaining this amazing toothpaste 8 7 7
7 8 9 2 5 3 not on the Saturday global
transmission I'm not gonna belabor this
I'm just gonna tell you that for just
your daily life and your gums and your
teeth and for regular viruses and
bacteria the patented nano silver we
have the Pentagon has come out and
documented and homeland security and
said this stuff kills the whole SARS
coronal at point-blank range well of
course it does it kills every virus
uh-huh but it's definitely they found
that and then this is this is 13 years
ago and the Pentagon uses the product we
have and the product we have and
private-label is about to be in Walmart
coming up they just ordered a massive
crap-ton of that not the one they have
this even better one that we have so I'm
just saying we're always cutting edge
thank to God I just I just go with the
research go with the spirit and we
always have it then the nano silver
toothpaste in the super blue with the
tea tree and the iodine that
super blues amazing then we have the
whitening toothpaste that has the Nano
silver and a lot more as well those are
both excellent re-enforced we're not
comments will discount despite all the
hell breaking loose
we have squirtable food in stock but we
have to package it and it's six to eight
weeks behind shipping it out to you
other people will lie to you the big old
Pinocchio noses we're not that's what's
going on you want trouble food you wanna
get delivered this thing of it is super
bad peaks in about 12 weeks in the US
the models show so you'll get your food
in for store.com and it's high-quality
it's a very little price they haven't
raised prices yet but I'm told it's next
week 24 store.com and bodies ultimate
ermine formula is back in stock as well
yeah so the New York State Attorney
General has also issued a cease and
desist order to Alex Jones over the
bogus toothpaste when people are
vulnerable they will be preyed upon the
entire concept of multi-level marketing
scams by the way it's often preying on
vulnerable people I know there are
exceptions but for the most part if you
have a steady and reliable job and a
good work like life balance you were not
going to fall for the idea of making a
hundred bucks selling who knows what by
recruiting other people and selling
products that people don't really want
because you are not in a situation where
that is appealing to you you are sort of
satisfied with your steady job and the
balance you're not looking to get a
second job and start selling whatever
these multi-level marketing scams and
network marketing scams they also prey
disproportionately on vulnerable people
and sometimes just on board people or
gullible people in the same way you have
people worried about the virus maybe
people who are more vulnerable based on
their age may be more vulnerable or even
maybe people who don't believe in like
normal medicine and so they are going to
fall for stuff like silver solution or
toothpastes they are going to be more
likely to fall for this stuff and you
know just think about it at its face the
virus is a respiratory illness which
means it gets into the lungs that's how
it infects you if you breathe in the
virus it goes past your mouth and your
teeth which is what you're dealing with
with toothpaste
it gets into your throat it gets into
your lungs what's brushing your teeth
going to do even if this garbage product
did kill the virus in your mouth
hypothetically how are you going to deal
with the fact that it's in the lungs
even if you swallow the toothpaste
unless you choke it's not going into
your lungs unless it goes down the wrong
pipe and also saying it kills the holes
hole SARS coronavirus
the common cold is sometimes a corona
virus common cold is is usually an upper
respiratory virus sometimes it's Rhino
virus sometimes it's picornavirus and
sometimes the common cold is a corona
virus strain he's suggesting that the
toothpaste kills the common cold for
which there is no known cure at all not
even even in a broader sense than corona
virus specifically really dangerous I
feel terribly for people falling for it
it's horrible that our judicial system
including attorneys general in multiple
states are having to at this time of
crisis deal with sending cease and
desist orders to people like Alex Jones
and Jim Baker although it's good that
they're doing it to be very clear it's
right that they're doing it it's just
disgusting that this is what they're
having to put time into horrible
horrible horrible stuff if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinka stinketh
lets you consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire library but you can
try it totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video